research has shown that humans possess
strong inductive biases which enable
them to quickly learn and generalize now
in order to instill the same useful
inductive biases into machines a paper
was presented by srijan Kumar at the
Europe's conference and it won the
outstanding paper of the Year award now
the paper is called using natural
language and program abstractions to
instill human inductive biases in
machines
now the paper focuses on using a
controlled stimulus space of
two-dimensional binary grids to define
the space of abstract Concepts that
humans have and a feedback loop of
collaboration between humans and
machines to understand the differences
in human and machine inductive biases
now um Francois Chalet believes that the
core of intelligence is efficient
generalization that's all there is to it
according to him and this is something
that neural networks in his opinion
cannot do
now um it might be the case that all
systems have their own inductive biases
and intelligence is an extremely broad
spectrum
it's important to make machines more
human-like to collaborate with them and
to understand their behavior synthesize
discrete programs running on a turing
machine computational model instead of a
neural network substrate offers promise
for the future of artificial
intelligence neural networks and program
induction should both be explored to get
a well-rounded view of intelligence
which works in multiple domains and
computational substrates and which can
acquire a diverse set of capabilities
natural language understanding in models
can also be improved by instilling human
language biases and programs into AI
models srijan used an experimental
framework consisting of two dual task
distributions one generated from Human
priors and one from machine priors in
order to understand the differences in
human and machine inductive biases
furthermore he demonstrated that
compressive abstractions can be used to
capture the essential structure of the
environment for more human-like Behavior
now this means that emergent
language-based inductive priors can be
distilled into artificial neural
networks and the artificial intelligence
models can be aligned to us the world
and indeed our values
humans possess strong inductive biases
which enable them to quickly learn to
perform various tasks and this is in
contrast to neural networks which lack
the same inductive biases and struggle
to learn them empirically from
observational data thus they have
difficulty generalizing to novel
environments due to their lack of prior
knowledge
recently meta learning has been used to
attempt to base neural networks with
useful inductive biases however agents
trained by this method may not always
acquire human-like strategies
now this paper explores the use of
co-training these agents on predicting
representations from natural language
task descriptions and program induction
models that add new learned Primitives
as a way to guide them towards more
human-like inductive biases
meta learning is a useful computational
framework to understand inductive biases
and is a method of machine learning in
which an agent is trained on a
distribution of tasks with the aim of
acquiring the underlying structure and
abstractions that these tasks have in
common this enables the agent to
generalize to novel environments and
tasks faster and with a smaller amount
of data the goal of meta learning is to
enable agents to learn from many sources
both from past experiences and from new
information now meta learning can be
used to speed up training for
reinforcement learning agents as well as
to improve the generalization ability of
reinforcement learning agents now
further experiments were conducted to
determine how humans were using their
high order Concepts to compress their
language descriptions in the same way
that program induction approaches add
new Concepts to the domain-specific
language to essentially compress the
program length the results of this
experiment provided evidence that
abstraction through compression in these
representations is a key driver of
human-like behavior in the downstream
metal learned agent when co-trained on
these representations
srijan's results showed that when guided
with representations from language and
programs The Meta learning agent not
only improved performance on task
distributions that humans are really
good at but also decreased performance
on control task distributions where the
humans perform poorly so this indicates
that the abstractions supported by these
representations in the substrate of
language or indeed a program is key in
the development of aligned artificial
intelligence with human-like
generalization capabilities aligned
values and behavior
now um I know I said I wouldn't publish
anything on mlst in January the reason
why I've accelerated this one is we've
got a book club in our Discord community
and you need to join and check it out
but we're going to be discussing
srijan's paper this afternoon uh
probably it's already happened by the
time you watch this video but um yeah
maybe you can join us on the next one so
without any further delay I give you SRI
jankuma
okay amazing here we go so I'm here with
um srijan Kumar and uh we're at new rips
and I've had an absolutely amazing week
I was speaking with Andrew lampan
yesterday and he told me about your
paper which actually won the outstanding
paper of the year at Europe's which is
an incredible achievement apparently
it's only awarded to 13 out of 10 000
submissions and this is already the most
prestigious AI conference in the world
so that's amazing
um now srijan's paper was called using
natural language and program
abstractions to instill human inductive
biases in machines very interesting to
our audience because we love meta
learning we love discrete program
synthesis we love
um you know abstraction and symbolic
generalization and like discrete
approaches to artificial intelligence
and we also love natural language
understanding and you know kind of a
symbol grounding Etc so it's like your
paper has got all of the components that
we love anyways three to introduce
yourself welcome uh yeah hi I'm srijan
Kumar I'm a fourth year PhD student
working with Tom Griffiths and John
Cohen and among other people and the
Princeton Neuroscience Institute so I'm
broadly interested in abstraction in
humans and neural networks and humans
we're going to kind of inductive biases
that gives us a strong abilities to
generalize across new tasks or learn new
tasks really quickly and in machines how
do we like instill those kinds of
adaptive biases to neural networks to
get them to behave like humans right now
that's really interesting we spoken to
Francois cholee a couple of times and he
has made the argument that neural
networks don't generalize very well or
certainly not in a sample efficient way
if you take into account the prize and
and the experience so he created this
thing called The Arc Challenge and loads
of folks on our Discord Community have
actually are working on entries for the
new version of that challenge change
using things like discrete program
synthesis you know over a DSL but anyway
why don't we start by just sketching out
the paper and then we'll make it a bit
pedagogical and we'll introduce meta
learning and discrete program synthesis
and Library learning and and how we do
the the language uh priors so um let's
start with the paper
yeah so uh uh the paper is really about
broadly uh how do you instill useful
human inductive biases and neural
network agents so humans have these have
this ability to learn things really fast
or pick up new things really quickly and
strongly generalize to novel tasks and
um uh and this is because we have really
strong inductive biases that are very
useful in bringing kind of good
knowledge that can help us generalize
very well in these tasks
and so the paper is really about how do
you kind of instill these inductive
biases uh doors of traction into neural
network agents uh so that's broadly what
the paper is about okay and um what's
the kind of um the technical framework
that you've used in the paper
yeah so uh we start out first by you
know asking like what are like
abstractions what are abstract
structures it's kind of a vague term so
you know in science we want to make
things more concrete so we can test
hypotheses uh so uh what we did is we
focused on a controlled stimulus space
of two-dimensional binary grids and the
first thing we asked is like what are
the space of abstract Concepts that
people have on the stimulus space and to
do that we did this experiment where we
basically used this technique called Gib
sampling people which pretty much puts
people on kind of a Gibb sampling Markov
chain where you have people making
decisions and then about about a grid
stimulus and then they pass that on to
another person and you repeat that
process over and over again until you
get kind of these samples on grid these
grid samples that kind of reflect human
the ground truth human priors on these
grids
um so I think in the paper if you like
look at something like figure two you
can see like
the samples from this kind of experiment
and you can kind of see that um there's
quite a bit of variation in the samples
but there are certain emergent abstract
Concepts that are kind of very Salient
to humans that persist across the
samples like lines and shapes and
letters these are the kinds of things
people are thinking about when they're
processing two-dimensional grids
um and so that's how we defined this
space of abstract Concepts people have
in kind of this domain and another thing
we did was we built a control
distribution where we sample from
machine prior so instead of having a
human in the loop in the Gibb sampler we
put a machine in the loop
um and what we get out of that into the
distribution
um so if you look at like figure two in
the paper you see like you know um uh
human versus machine samples
um you can see that the two
distributions look kind of similar but
you know as a human you can look at the
control distributions tell something
something's kind of off and that's
because it's devoid of certain abstract
Concepts like lines shapes letters Etc
um and so what we did then to test kind
of acquisition of human inductive priors
on our on neural network agents is we
formulated each of these grids as a
reinforced learning game
um so it's based on the game uh
Minesweeper or Battleship
um so basically cover all the tiles on
the grid and then the goal is to
sequentially reveal all the tiles in the
grid until you've done all the reward
tiles all the red tiles with as little
white tiles as possible so it's all also
like red is positive reward white is
negative reward
um and uh so it's like a two-part paper
basically the first part is kind of
defining this whole um kind of
experimental Paradigm to show that
humans and machines have different
ducted biases because the kind the tasks
that humans are good at are the tasks
that
um RL agents are bad at and the tasks
that all agents are bad at are good at
humans are actually also bad at so you
get this double association between
humans and agents showing that these two
systems have different inductive biases
so that's the first part of the paper
just showing that humans and agents have
different ductive biases the second part
of the paper is about
um kind of we how do you actually
instill human inductive biases to get
the oral agent to behave like a human
and to answer that we kind of we
co-train the agent on natural language
description and program induction
abstractions in order to guide them
during learning to learn human-like
conductive biases and then become good
at the tasks that humans are good at and
importantly also bad at the tasks that
humans are bad at so that's a broad
overview of the paper amazing so um the
first thing so I'm really interested in
prior's um you know human
anthropocentric priors and whether the
abstractions that we use to think about
the world are deducible from those
prayers and surely cites Elizabeth
spellke I think you know she has this
this notion of core knowledge that
humans have to understand and think
about the world Melanie Mitchell talks
about two modes of understanding we have
a human mode of understanding let's say
large language models have a different
mode of understanding so I suppose like
first of all do you have any intuition
on why we should make priors more
human-like and why we should expect
computer is to think more like humans
yeah it's a really good question
um so the example I usually give is
um I think with things like large
language models and kind of diffusion
models and things like that where you
have to input like a prompt and then you
get a picture or a text or something and
then you it looks kind of right but not
exactly what you want so you implement
another prompt this kind of feedback
loop is kind of like collaboration
between humans and machines
um and uh one thing with humans is that
uh you know we find it really easy to
collaborate with people that are kind of
similar to us that think similarly to us
um and uh and so uh you know one reason
why we want to instill human biases and
machines is that if you want to
collaborate with machines and work
together with them then it can be more
amenable for them to kind of have
explainable behavior and you know and
you can kind of predict their behavior
if they have similar biases to you oh
interesting yeah I understand that
because I suppose the cognitive eyes
that we have they inform how we think
and how we communicate which ideas are
intelligible and understandable by other
humans okay
um that's really really interesting so
um why don't we bring in this this
notion of generalization so so shortly
you know one of the reasons he advocates
for let's say a discrete program search
is that he thinks intelligence literally
is efficient generalization so um as
well as it being you know intelligible
and anthropocentric it's also about
symbolic generalization and surely would
point out probably that neural networks
can't represent infinite objects they're
not Turing machines There's Something
Magic about these discrete programs so
would you agree with that
um
yeah I think well the kind of position I
would have
um is kind of uh
all systems have their own inductive
biases and
um ml systems even though they might not
generalize at the things that humans are
good at they generalize at things that
you know they're good at
um and so broadly intelligence is kind
of like this broad spectrum
um and so uh you know every so you know
if you want to talk about human-like
generalization then things like discrete
program synthesis and symbolicness um
come to play
um and uh so that's the kind of uh kind
of the way I see it yeah interesting
yeah I think um sholay kind of says oh
there's type 1 and type 2 generalization
so it's a little bit like there's some
underlying um domain so in the in the
discrete domain generalization means
something different between the
continuous domain
yeah
um yeah for sure and a lot of the kinds
of things that
um people are gonna generally good at
generalizing at
um come from uh their kind of discrete
domains like uh planning or arithmetic
or these kinds of things that can be
implemented in symbolic discrete
algorithms
um and you know it's it's actually like
kind of a toss-up whether we're innately
good at that or whether that's something
you know if you put someone through
school where they have to learn like you
know symbolic algorithms then maybe that
also helps us learn
um how to how to be good at this kind of
stuff
um
so uh yeah I think like you know these
are those kinds of interesting questions
to
yeah that's a real mystery isn't it
whether it's uh you know like Daniel
Kahneman style or some weird mix of the
two maybe that's just a cognitive model
that we're projecting on to how we think
and it's actually much more complicated
than that but
um why don't we break down the framework
here so um uh some of the top level
um technical kind of architectural items
you've used are you know meta learning
reinforcement learning discrete program
search maybe we should start with um
discrete program search because I'm a
huge fan of dreamcoder for example and
um most of these approaches use let's
say a domain specific language and they
um do library learning and and kind of
dynamic abstraction and you know it's a
really interesting setup I'm very
excited about it so how do you
understand discrete program uh synthesis
yeah so program and synthesis or you
know in cognitive science circles we
call it like program induction
um broadly is like kind of an
interesting class of models um that's
kind of takes a very different approach
from the current neural network based
approaches which is um you know if you
have a problem you define like the
relevant abstractions of the problem in
a domain-specific language
um and uh solutions to kind of problems
in this domain will be kind of
compositionally composed of things from
this set of Primitives that you don't
that you define in this domain specific
language
um so uh it's it's kind of like
um you know uh an AI you know there's
always a tension between what do you
build in and what do you learn from and
the program induction stuff is
definitely closer to the what do you
what do you build in from the beginning
um kind of side of the spectrum uh so
it's a good thing to kind of look at the
a broad class of approaches like neural
networks and also program induction uh
just to see the whole Spectrum okay
fantastic and um you're also using a
meta learning and reinforcement learning
we had a great um conversation with Dr
Tom zahavi from deepmind he's big into
meta learning but um can you just like
give us a bit of an elevator pitch on
why do you think meta learning is is
really useful in this situation so
matter learning is a really good
computational framework to
um understand uh kind of rigorously
inductive bias because you can think of
meta learning as kind of a process where
you train on a distribution of tasks and
that task and that distribution of tasks
kind of embeds some kind of
inductive prior and once you learn this
inductive prior then once you do another
task from this distribution then that's
good that inductive prior helps you
learn that new task faster and so it's a
really good framework for if you want to
study things like generalization and
stuff like that okay fantastic now um
the thing I really want to get to is it
gives you a natural language
understanding we have this problem of
pragmatics and grounding and that
there's always this problem of of how do
we align AI models to the world to our
values and and
um and and what you're saying also is
how do we align it to our cognitive
priors which is very interesting so so
you said you've instilled human language
biases with language as well as well as
programs how do you like in in your
training architecture how do you link
the language to the model
yeah it's a good question so during
um during learning when
um the RL agent is kind of playing the
game while it's thinking about what
action to use
um it also has to simultaneously predict
a dis a language description that a
human wrote of the kind of underlying
grid task
um and so this it's it's basically
implemented as an auxiliary loss to the
RL objective and if you add this
auxiliary loss then that will kind of
change its kind of the way it learns
during training and as a result it will
it will have different generalization
behavior and what we show in the paper
is more human-like generalization
Behavior if you co-train on human
generated language uh particularly
okay not using some kind of a language
model to represent let's say utterances
in a vector space and then you're
feeding that into the training program
absolutely yeah we use um Roberta it's a
lot it's a large language model it's
very popular and so we push the
descriptions through Roberta it gives us
an embedding and then you can kind of
use uh make a like have kind of a mean
squared error auxiliary loss predicting
the Roberta embedding amazing okay so um
tell us a little bit about your
experimental framework and and
presumably you you ended up with with
priors which were far more
anthropomorphic
yeah um so uh so I I guess I mentioned
the first half of the paper before we
defined this kind of experimental
firmware where you have these two dual
tasks distributions
um human ones generated from Human
priors and one generated from machine
priors we call the control distribution
um and so
you know in our Baseline experiment we
showed that if you train an RL agent on
the human generated task
then it will actually generalize better
to the machine generated tasks than the
human generated tasks whereas humans
find the human generated task easier uh
so you know this so the question is how
do you Rectify that and basically we
explored a variety of representations
you can co-train on using auxiliary loss
like um human generated natural language
descriptions or synthetic natural
language descriptions or representations
from program induction uh with only uh
Primitives from the DSL or
representation program induction that
also include Library learning
um and what we found was that if you
co-train our representations
with compressive abstractions then you
get more human-like Behavior Uh and so
compressive abstractions are kind of if
you look in the paper I think the best
way to think about it is uh if you look
in the paper on the in the first figure
we have synthetic language descriptions
and human generated language
descriptions so the synthetic language
description is like this tile is red
this tile is why it's a very literal
description of the board there's no
abstraction but if you get people to
describe these boards we kind of
naturally use use certain abstract
Concepts like oh this kind of looks like
a you or this kind of looks like a
hammer or things like that and these
abstract Concepts we kind of naturally
use in everyday life to compress the our
description lengths and those kind of
compressive abstractions capture the
essential structure of our environment
and so as a result if you co-train on
representation with these compressive
abstractions you get more human-like
Behavior right and what really is what
really excites me is over you know like
go fight people they try to represent
knowledge and you know even in the arc
challenge most of the folks represent
the priors using some kind of discrete
representation and it's brittle it
doesn't work very well and there's
there's always this problem with priors
of where do they come from and how
platonic are they and how intelligible
are they and what you've done is you've
argued that language descriptions right
and these program abstractions can act
as repositories for human inductive
biases that can be distilled into
artificial neural networks so it's
almost like you're taking the let's say
emergent inductive priors which exist in
language and you're capturing them into
into the model
yeah for sure
um yeah so uh what I like about the
paper is that
um
you know the thing about inductive
biases people usually think you have to
kind of have a different architecture or
kind of train the agent and like kind of
a weird way or build it in from scratch
basically
or have these priors be explicit enough
for you to like actually you know
formalize them but in the paper we argue
that you know you can kind of harvest
these priors implicitly from kind of a
repository of these inductive biases
which can exist in language or in
programs if you're able to make them
more explicit
um and so learning useful inductive
biases can be also from data and not
just from like building it from scratch
amazing well folks this is a really
really exciting paper so as I said it's
called using natural language and
program abstractions to instill human
inductive biases in machines
um srijan just before you go how are you
finding the conference what are you
excited about
uh yeah the conference is awesome
um you know like I'm meeting a lot of
people whose stuff I've been reading for
a long time and then now I get to put a
face on the papers
um and uh yeah I think uh what I find
exciting personally is
um kind of the variety of disciplines
and backgrounds that are using machine
learning they're kind of converging on
the same kinds of questions and
hypotheses uh and that's been exciting
to see in the conference amazing well
sweet John thank you very much for
joining us today thank you